- I came up with, I got something.
♫ We're inseparable
(static)
- Okay, love you.
Morning YouTube.
Ah, Monday morning.
Walking here in the high line,
which is gorgeous by the way.
If you come to New York City,
you've got to check it out.
Right, D Rock?
- Yeah.
- I don't think we take
advantage of it enough.
You guys may know Vayner X.
Created a holding company,
got the agency, Vayner Media
on this side, got the
gallery on this side,
Pure Wow sitting under there, so.
We have a lot to do.
- [Man] Yes we do.
- And so I'm dickin'
around, doing my normal
exciting entrepreneurship,
let's do clever, blah blah.
Fuck that.
Get a podcast infrastructure
around the gallery,
and get the right pieces in place for it.
That's smart.
Start doing a pull up.
I'm getting fired up.
As a matter of fact.
- [Announcer] We interrupt our program
to bring you this important message.
- Calling all creators right now.
We need to create a content
army who are designers,
who love to make meme
content on Instagram,
video editors who can take
this video ramp for example,
that we've just been doing and create 19
pieces of content and love that idea.
You know D Rock?
You know what I like about you and I?
We like the dirty work.
I'm a creator at VaynerMedia.com.
We'll create a Google form,
imacreator@vaynermedia.com
Full-time job, you need to come in and
rock and roll 40 to 100 hours a week,
depending on how we structure it.
Let's do this.
- [Narrator] Now back to our show.
- So there's that.
That was fun.
A little commercial break.
Jets lost.
That's huge.
I guess I forgot I was in
college the '97 Jets season.
When I knew they were gonna
be the worst team in football.
I'm excited about today.
Morning Snapchat.
D Rock and I hustling.
What's your Monday focus?
What's yours D Rock?
- [D Rock] Being the best I can be today.
- Nice, you answered it.
By the way, What we're
building at Hudson Yard,
will not wait.
What they're building at Hudson Yards,
this sculpture right outside our office,
is fucking going to be awesome.
(beep) (bling)
She's coming from Trenton.
Are you in Trenton?
Are you coming up?
I came up with it, I've got something.
We've got something.
Andy, to his credit, 'cause it's teamwork.
But what we did is we
created an event called
Giving Away Free Food
party at Wine Library.
Like this Saturday, for example,
we will will give you a coupon,
you then, can apply that
$10 towards free food.
You don't have to buy anything.
You don't have to do anything.
You just leave.
You just leave with a high-end cheese and
piece of sausage and
go to Shorehills Mall.
I think it's going to be fucking awesome.
I'm excited about it.
All right, D Rock, you have to go
an important senior
executive meeting with a
client that can grow,
so this is off limits,
but having a good day so far and
wine talk, and now Vayner
Media domination talk.
(phone dialing)
Here's where we meet about micro fast.
Literally, on a daily
basis, I am scrutinizing
12 to 15 hours a day and trying to fill in
as much stuff and as smart
of stuff into that bucket.
Right?
So that's micro speed.
(phone ringing)
Big idea.
Let's do a food truck event.
Tweet it out.
Put it on my Instagram.
Inbox comes in.
Email the team at Wine Library.
- Hello?
- Hey.
And now, I did it before I did it.
- Hey man.
- Hey Brandon.
So this whole food truck thing.
So if you're in Berkeley
Heights New Jersey,
you need to come.
Ah, sorry Brandon, I'm
just filming my vlog.
YouTube is now very near and dear to me.
I now speak to YouTube when I do DailyVee.
Do you understand, Brandon?
- I understand.
- Awesome.
All right, so anyway, me
and Tyler are going to keep
sending you as they come in.
You know, always in the
summer when I spend a week
with my dad in New Jersey as a family,
it always gets my juices going, and so
you always see an August, early September
push for me on the family business.
And so, doing a bunch of cool stuff.
Please come and visit the store.
Check it out.
We're doing a lot of rad stuff.
How are you?
- Pleasure.
- Such a pleasure, how are you?
- Just for all content.
- [Gary] So nice.
- I know you talk about
being, you know, self aware.
- 100% I genuinely believe
the biggest mistake
that most artists make
is they don't realize
if they are business as well.
- [Man] Right.
- And the biggest part,
and the biggest mistake
that business people make is they don't
realize if their art, I mean
the amount of business quant,
math, sales conversion,
making shit happen,
guys and gals that also
think that their pottery
is beautiful or they can sing.
Sit, sit, sit.
Thank you, man.
It's super nice.
- Yeah, and this one is just to thank you
for meeting with us today.
- Ah, I love it.
Curtis.
I might actually send it to him, because,
Curtis, I got something for you.
Can't wait to share it.
Nice.
Having the balance of doing something nice
for somebody on the way up, karma.
Giving back to the game.
And then fucking 30 minutes
with fucking LeBron,
or ARod, or fucking,
you know, Kodak Black.
- Yeah.
- Right?
Like what I'm trying to do.
- [Man] Right.
Cool.
- All fucking my time, which
is where I make my money.
People are confused that I'm taking
my own advice, if they watch.
That's why I work 18 hours a day,
so I can do this while run
a $200 million business.
Every fucking day I'm
giving away things for free.
The hardest thing, my
time, which comes out
of my leisure, my
relaxing, my family time,
so why would I be the biggest artist?
Because I would fucking
make paintings for everybody
who I strategically thought mattered, and
I'm really good at knowing
where the world goes.
Time?
- [Woman] Yeah, time.
- All right.
- Thank you so much, can
I get a quick picture
with you?
- Of course.
You know, taking time
off, I would be lying
if I didn't feel frustrated
because of August.
Not in the same patterns.
Break up patterns.
So we have things to do.
We have the podcast.
We have me driving a fuckin'
25 to 50% top line growth,
which you should 100% do.
We have a lot to do.
Get a podcast infrastructure
around the gallery
and get the right pieces in place.
That's smart.
That's smart, concise.
Just had a super high level meeting with
our business partners from Related,
Steven Ross from the
Dolphins, his whole crew,
his infrastructure to work
with me, Ryan and Mary Kate
from Pure Wow, and the
gallery, the holding company,
under Vayner X that supports that.
Just, media company of the future.
(static)
That's what we're doing, YouTube.
- Do you want us to write
a letter that you would
send off as a letter of recommendation?
- For what?
- For, he's gonna
apply to a bunch of VC jobs.
- Okay.
- [Man] He wants you to give
him a stamp of recommendation.
- Get me a three minute
call with him next week,
while I'm traveling.
- [Man] Okay, cool.
- So I can talk him out of VC jobs.
All you fuckers trying
to get these VC jobs,
it's a huge mistake when
you're not ready for it.
Everybody thinks VC jobs are like fuckin',
you know, like playing
backyard basketball.
These are financial, these
institutions have massive
financial rigor and experience, like.
And more importantly,
the VC train is like not,
you know, it's a little tired.
Ah man, I don't know.
Everybody just wants to be a VC
before they ever proved anything.
Unless you've gone out
and built a big business,
and had an exit and made a ton of money,
or you're the 1% of the 1%
in the financial fuckin' apex
of schools, organizations,
you're not getting a VC job that matters.
(man talking off-mic)
- Hey how you doing?
- Good to see you.
How you doin', man, are you well?
- Always.
- Good.
- How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- Good to see you.
- Good to see you man.
Hey thanks.
Let's do it.
I've been fascinated with
this concept of if we get
multiple people tasting wine blind.
I'm just going to ask some questions,
so that the conversations flows.
Feel free to talk about anything
that's important to you.
Cool?
Okay, you ready Seth?
Hey guys, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
Obviously, I've been super
excited about this blind
brown paper bags concept.
8:41, going to another meeting now to talk
about some projects.
Probably going to wrap up at like 11.
I will send you a video
to prove it, D Rock.
(mumbles) Gonna go to sleep
after this, no I'm just kidding.
Good day.
I haven't eaten in like four days.
Sipping like three
glasses of wine, I'm like
not even drinking and I'm like,
I feel weirdly tipsy.
Welcome to the first episode
of What Wine Goes With.
Real quick.
So many comments here.
Please leave more questions
in the YouTube comments.
This is an interesting
point, from Adian Pit Prints.
This guys consistently goes to meetings,
manages a massive
business, manages social,
and still has time to like fan's comments.
Respect.
I appreciate that comment,
because I'm trying to
do macro things and run
a $200 million business,
and build one of the biggest
brand entrepreneurship,
but I think one of the
ways to get there is
to continue to do things
like this, my man.
APM, like reading your
comment and liking it.
I'm a big fan of getting
dirt under you fingernails,
and then cleaning it off and going to a
white cloth, VIP super tied out dinner.
There's just something about that.
And that's why I like
your comments, my man.
Because, I don't give
a fuck how big I get,
I'm never fucking going fancy on you.
♫ Runnin' runnin' lights
♫ Skippin', skippin' signs
♫ Fearin' for my life
♫ Here safe in my car
♫ Tell me to go right
♫ I'll keep swervin' left all night
♫ Da, da, da, da, da, dah
da, da, da, da, da, dah